Olivia Jade and Jackson Guffey are
officially back together
two months after calling it quits the
musician publicly proclaimed his love by
posting a black-and-white photo of him
and Olivia kissing with the caption lil
monkey I love you stay with me
a source close to Olivia Jade tells ET
the couple is doing much better and had
a really good summer together adding
Jackson never posted on social media
about any of the women he's dated before
quote it's definitely a way of showing
his love and support for her and to let
people know they are a couple darlin
stay with another source told ET in May
that the pair had broken up noting
Olivia's friends were shocked by the
split quote he's pretty low-key and
wanted to help her stay out of the
limelight and move on their breakup came
on the heels of the college admissions
scandal then you can do what you want
back in May a source told ET quote
olivia is having a very hard time
dealing with this and for the most part
she's cut herself off from her mother
and is going out and partying a lot but
just last month another source told ET
that Olivia's relationship with her mom
Lori Loughlin has improved everybody
makes mistakes be no parent is perfect
last week both Olivia and her older
sister Bella returned to social media to
wish their mom a happy birthday we're
just a nice normal family you know like
we don't learn we don't have anything
outrageous really happening
[Music]